The Joe Rogan Experience I want to go
back because we glossed over that we
came back when we're in the Green Room
you were talking about uh your blood
pressure you were talking about uh your
inflammation and how good you feel just
five days off of booze what a difference
it's made yeah I feel phenomenal my
blood pressure dropped immediately into
perfect blood pressure like it's 140
over 90. if I'm partying hard and then
two days after drinking it's 120 over
70. two days yeah and my blood pressure
drops I mean my stomach my stomach
starts making noises like really
aggressive like didn't it inflame at
first yeah it super inflamed and then it
just starts going
like there's that's dude that's pretty
[ __ ] good it's a good impression of
whatever was happening I mean that's
another level I was farting so
aggressively the first day not drinking
I was at the store and I was trying to
have a conversation with something about
disc golf and I was have my ass in the
main room towards the bathroom and I was
ripping farts that were like just coming
like all this I think my inflammation's
so bad it kind of blocks up my stomach
and I was gassy as [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
don't think you account for how much you
like when you drink normal bird drinking
which is a lot yeah you also eat crazy
crazy wild I don't eat bad last night I
grab those tacos in the bell pepper
brought it home and I went I don't want
this [ __ ] I
multiple homeless people said hey are
you eating that food and you go yeah I
took it to eat it yeah I wanted to but I
got home so you were walking around and
homeless people were asking you for your
food yeah
Welcome to Austin Joe well where are you
walking where homeless people are asking
you from the book from the Vulcan so you
walked all the way to no no I just
walked outside the Vulcan and there was
a plethora of homeless people going hey
can I get that food from you is that a
doggy bag can I have it
then because I took it to eat it well at
first I took it because I hadn't eaten
all day right uh and you brought it back
and decided not to eat it I got home
here's one of the things that happened a
little bit when I went I got this full
metabolic blood panel full comprehensive
uh concierge doctor visit
and the guy said uh we were talking
about uh changing my lifestyle
and I was you know there's a period of
time Tom knows this where I was throwing
up while I slept and breathing in my
lungs it's called aspirating and it was
[ __ ] it was giving me hardcore uh uh
acid reflux
and I went to the doctor and the doctor
said listen man this is going to affect
your career you're not gonna be able to
talk I was losing my voice like crazy he
goes you got to stop eating before you
go to bed
and I stopped entirely I stopped eating
before I went to bed because because I
saw direct like reflection in my career
I could do it and so then when this
other doctor he's like you need to lose
weight and he's like here's why I think
you can do that because you did it with
the eating before you went to bed so you
can change your lifestyle it's it's
possible so last night when I went home
I brought the food because that's my
impulse set it down called mans and
Peter they came up to my room they ate
it and I went I'll be throwing this up
in my throat all [ __ ] night all night
I won't sleep I won't feel rested I'll
go into the podcast feeling like [ __ ] I
didn't eat any of it I didn't eat any of
it good for you yeah but um it's a great
story
do you want to call [ __ ]
no he just says the story sucked
I mean it's a tall tale
so
did not it couldn't even tell you what
was in the tacos couldn't even tell you
those tacos are good let's uh CM
Smokehouse it's six days we're six days
have you ever have you already weighed
differently I lost like eight pounds
how's your tits in your arm Ari could
barely hold the mic last night oh okay I
have to keep switching arms from the
push-ups I can't I can't hold a phone to
my to my head for like two minutes I
have to switch arms dead amazing do you
do I'll show you a picture right now
right now I'm looking at you no no no
shirtless I took this picture I sent you
a picture of me shirtless shut the [ __ ]
up your picture was I opened your box
wasn't real and it's unreal like I
wanted to leak it yeah I'm on
testosterone unlike the liver King I'll
tell you the truth
the be honest be honest is that a good
picture no
I'll say no and I didn't even look at it
you got shoulders and chest though not
bad right your [ __ ] is a good solid [ __ ]
thank you thank you especially limp yeah
thank you
I've loved it I got it hard
I walked by the mirror and I was like I
look good I was like I'm gonna take a
picture something better I'll fluff
myself alone in a hotel room to walk by
the mirror just to see myself just to
see your max potential just no just to
feel like oh that's normal yeah we put a
rubber band around your dick and balls
like the whole thing sure yeah just keep
it all together all together in a
package and just [ __ ] keep that blood
in there they used to have
Speedos that had [ __ ] rings in them that
would shove your [ __ ] from the front and
you look awesome
you almost are aspirated
so you you go to this concierge service
you get all this of this blood panel
done yeah and um what is the guy what
kind of advice is he giving you well
first of all he thought I was a liar
like when we sat down he was like much
like Ari he goes how much you drink
you're honest I tell them everything and
he goes don't work out and I said excuse
me he goes do not work out I don't want
you in a gym I don't want you doing
anything he goes you are high risk to
literally to have a stroke a heart
attack and I went actually and by the
way we did uh court ordered artery scans
on my on my neck did uh kg and
everything everything did everything
and he's like and we haven't gotten the
results yet and I said I actually go to
cardiologists every six months I'm I
work out pretty [ __ ] hard I'm not
going to stop working out it's kind of
my thing as I wake up I party and then I
wake up and then I work out hard as [ __ ]
I'm I think I'm fine he goes trust me
the what you're telling me if you work
out you'll have a stroke and you're
gonna die actually probably because and
he's probably telling you that because
most people would but is he telling you
it's based on the volume of alcohol
based on just a conversation and
interview of like how much do you drink
yeah because my weight most people who
were drinking oh yeah like most drinks
would not be actually dead yeah yeah and
so I told him I said hey man I'm not
going to change anything I'll wait if
you want to have that conversation when
we get my blood work back and all my
tests that's fine but I said I don't
think you're gonna find any blockage
anywhere because I've already had all
these I'm already on medication I'm on
blood dinners I think I'm gonna be fine
I'm gonna continue to work out I'll I'll
scale it back a titch but
but like I mean just usually I go until
like I work out pretty [ __ ] hard and
so yeah I worked out with you at on a
gym yeah you get after it and so
blood work comes back like two days
later three days later and he's like I
don't know what to tell you he's like
none of it makes sense he's like you
have no blockage you have from what
you're telling me either you're lying to
me or he's got a test for the mental
Dream well I think you're you're a very
unusual specimen and Tom and I were
talking about this like if you didn't
drink and party and you just like worked
out all the time I think you'd be like a
freak athlete I really do
I really do I think if you were I think
you're one of those guys that if you
just like didn't party at all and hit
the gym and like trained your whole life
you'd you'd be a [ __ ] a freak I
really think that yeah I don't disagree
yeah I I really enjoy I really enjoy
working out yeah I do enjoy it and I
work out really hard
um working out sober hard I don't think
I've ever worked out this hard sober
with Direction you work out you get
drunk and then work out I have yeah wow
he drinks wine on the treadmill in the
world have you ever done it it's so much
fun no no no it's still [ __ ] bad no
it's the best I like to get high and
work out there yeah oh my God I like to
get really high like so high I'm scared
of how I shoot hoops is fun
yeah you know where the ball's going
like you feel it more high in poker I
see through people oh that's interesting
yeah you see the lies yeah I just go
right I just like I know what
everybody's holding that's great oh wow
Edibles or or sweet sweet and then every
break every break you gotta run back to
your car smoke a bunch and come back get
more power get more power yeah but
that's why I'm saying Edibles would
Edibles give you the same result I don't
know it might be two like two shirts or
turn to play
I can't handle trees yeah yeah
so but getting high and lifting weights
man you just [ __ ] you feel like every
fiber of your muscles like what are you
doing chin ups when you're high yeah
it's like you feel like
you feel it all like you feel like all
the fibers working together
like stretching when you're high
stretching's good
yoga would be though yoga I bet yoga
amazing High yeah well in in India a lot
of the yogis they smoke chilums they do
hashish oh and they then they do yoga
how about Hot Box yoga
and just fill that room up with weed
smoke yeah like like one of them smoke
machines like yeah
dude I know a guy with a Hot Yoga Studio
in his office yeah me that's what I was
gonna say yeah let's do it you're the
guy
it's right here wait you crank up the
the heat no I have a Hot Yoga Studio in
in one of my you didn't see it I didn't
show it to you and babe I don't know
it's wild yeah I have a hot yoga to turn
it up to the right it's bigger than this
room and it has its own uh heating
system and so it's completely isolated
from the rest of the gym so you can
crank it up to 105 whatever the [ __ ] you
want you want to get crazy and go 130.
[ __ ]